there are only a few countries in the
world that don't have rabies for someone
that's due to isolation and strong
quarantine measures the same way that
being an island nation has helped you
see rabies is a particularly nasty
disease it swells your brain it changes
your behavior it makes you paranoid and
delirious and in constant pain and then
it kills there's a reason that in French
it's known as Mirage the range rabies
was terrifying in 19th century report
when he bite or scratch through any
stray or wild dog and there were a lot
of those could kill you in a horrible
way I mean it almost certainly would
they were they're actually only around
1200 UK deaths from rabies in the whole
century the risk was actually really low
but it terrifying Britain's so that was
what we didn't he'll call a war on rates
pet dogs had to be muzzled wild and
stray dogs would kill those are battle
in the press and in public opinion
between dog lovers and dog Muslims
rabies was a threat but I'll now to the
all proportion but those controls worked
the last case of rabies cause my British
channel was in 1922 and there is a
certain pride in the fact that Britain
is free of rabies I mean the UK does
have a similar virus a few bats but
unless you're a professional vet or
who's white the odds of a backbiter near
zero we count ourselves as having white
detail but even today you will still see
scare mongering right-wing tabloid
headlines about new registrants and how
foreigners can break through our borders
and let it in so most busy harbours in
Britain you will still find a sign like
this it's a reminder that bringing any
animal into Britain on a private plane
or boat is illegal not because it's
actually significant threat of rabies
even if a rate the dog was smuggled in
that it sees what it's practically far
it wouldn't cause
but the reason that sign is there is the
same reason that Britain is free of
rabies because it's terrifying because
it's still a specter in the public
consciousness and because being free of
it just like being an island nation it's
part of our national identity